Suppose you have m sorted runs in
slow memory where each run is of size
s items.
The total number of items,
by the way, is n equals m times s.
Your task is to merge all of these
sorted runs into a single sorted run
that would complete
the merge sort algorithm.
An easy scheme based on the classical
merge sort idea is to merge
pairs of runs.
And then pairs of pairs and so
on until you get a final single run.
Now observe what happens at each level.
At each level k starting at 0, the size
of the run is 2 to the k times s.
Now it's probably not too
hard to sort out the details.
But just to be clear,
let's quickly walk through the steps.
Start by considering a pair of runs,
each of size 2 to the k minus 1 times s.
Let's call these A and B.
Initially A and B live in slow memory.
Your goal is to produce a merged run,
C, which will hold 2 to
the k times s items.
Let's call the output buffer C.
To execute this merge, let's maintain
three buffers in fast memory.
Each fast memory buffer will
hold L elements corresponding to
the transaction size.
Let's use two of these buffers for
storing elements from A and B, and
the third one for
storing elements of the output.
I'll refer to the fast memory
buffers as A hat, B hat and C hat.
To perform the merge, start by reading
one L sized block from each of A and
B sitting in slow memory and
move them to fast memory.
Then carry out the following steps.
You'll iterate until you've
either read all of A or all of B.
You'll locally merge elements
from A hat and B hat into C hat.
Do that until you run out of
elements from A hat or B hat or
until you fill the output
buffer of C hat.
If you empty A hat or B hat then just
read more elements from slow memory.
If you fill C Hat, then just flush the
result to slow memory and empty C Hat.
Finally if you exhaust A or
you exhaust B you just need to copy
the remaining elements from B or A.
So when all is said and done, what does
it cost to merge the pair of runs A, B?
This scheme only ever loads elements
from A or B from slow memory once.
And it only writes a given
output block once.
So, that's a total of 2 to
the K + 1 x S / L transfers.
Regarding comparisons, there are also
just a linear number of them.
Now, this is all just to
merge one pair A and B.
So, let's go back to
the original merge tree.
The analysis you did was just for
one pair.
Now, at each level you can
count the number of pairs.
That will be n divided
be 2 to the k times s.
What about the total number of levels?
That's just log base
2 of n divided by s.
Combining these costs over all levels.
Here then are the total costs.
The number of transfers is two
times n over L log n over s.
The comparisons are n log n over s.
A good question to ask yourself now is,
self, is this good or bad?